>> Tucker: WELCOME TO TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT A LOT MORE THAN
HALF OF THE ENTIRE POPULATION O
THE ENTIRE STATE OF ARIZONA
LIVES IN MARICOPA COUNTY.
THE CITIES OF MESA, TEMPE, AND
SCOTTSVILLE AND FOR A LARGE PAR
PHOENIX OUR IN THE COUNTY
COUNTIES OR DISPARATE IF YOU
WANT TO WIN STATEWIDE IN ARIZON
EAT YOU HAVE TO WIN MARICOPA
COUNTY.
TONIGHT WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHO
HAS ONE MARICOPA COUNTY.
BECAUSE OFFICIALS ARE NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO FINISHING THE COUNT.
48 HOURS AFTER THE VOTING
STOPPED, 633,000 BALLOTS ARE
STILL UNCOUNTED IN ARIZONA.
MORE THAN 400,000 OF THOSE ARE
IN MARICOPA COUNTY.
WHEN WILL WE KNOW THE RESULTS?
LAST NIGHT, ELECTION OFFICIALS
CLAIMED THEY HAVE A NEW TELLER
FOR US BY 8:00 P.M. EASTERN, TH
BEGINNING OF A SHOW.
BY THE END OF THE NIGHT THEY HA
FINISHED COUNTING FEWER THAN
70,000 MORE VOTES.
THEN THEY SAID THEY WOULD HAVE
FINAL TOTALS BY FRIDAY, TOMORROW
.
KNOW, TODAY THAT COUNTY
OFFICIALS THAT THEY DON'T EXPEC
TO ANNOUNCE THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTIONS UNTIL NEXT WEEK AT TH
EARLIEST.
>> WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THE
VOTES WILL BE COUNTED IN TOTAL,
THOSE 400,000 PLUS VOTES?
TICKET WE WILL BE GOING INTO
NEXT WEEK, THERE ARE SOME
WEDNESDAY-TUESDAYS PURSUANT TO
ARIZONA LAW, BUT I THINK WE WIL
SEE THE LANE SHARE WRAP UP BY
EARLY NEXT WEEK.
>> EARLY NEXT WEEK, CAN YOU GIV
ME A DAY?
ARE WE TALKING MONDAY?
HE GATE MAY BE, AS LONG AS YOU
WON'T HOLD ME TO IT.
>> CAN YOU TELL US MISTER
ELECTION OFFICIAL WHEN WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO FIND OUT WHO WON THE
ELECTION.
A B, AS LONG AS YOU DON'T HOLD
ME TO IT.
THAT WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
MARICOPA COUNTY SUPERVISORS.
WHAT YOU DID NOT HEAR IN THAT
EXCHANGE WAS AN APOLOGY.
THE GUY IN CHARGE OF ELECTION
RESULTS NEVER SAID SORRY FOR NO
PROVIDING THOSE RESULTS.
IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND THIS.
IS NOT A RESOURCE PROBLEM
CERTAINLY.
THE BUDGET OF MARICOPA COUNTY I
ABOUT FOUR AND A HALF BILLION.
FOR PERSPECTIVE, THE ENTIRE
HOOVER DAM HOT $800 MILLION TO
BUILD AND THAT IS IN THE
ADJUSTED DOLLARS PAID FOR THE
PRICE OF FIVE OVER DAMS,
MARICOPA COUNTY CAN'T EVEN COUN
THE BALLOTS IN A SINGLE
STATEWIDE ELECTION IN A COUNTRY
THAT CLAIMS TO CARE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
THEY CAN'T MANAGE TO LET PEOPLE
VOTE ON ELECTION DAY.
ON ELECTION DAY GROTE ACCORDING
TO THE COUNTY 70 OF 223 POLLING
PLACES SUFFERED PROBLEMS WITH
VOTING MACHINES, MACHINES THEY
COUNTY PLAYED MILLIONS FOR JUST
RECENTLY AND THEIR FAILURE
DISENFRANCHISED MOSTLY
REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
ONE POLL WORKER REPORTED THAT 2
REJECTED.
IT WOULD CALL THAT THIRD WORLD,
BUT ACTUALLY IT'S BENEATH THIRD
WORLD.
MUST REQUIRE VOTER ID, THEY
DON'T WAIT DAYS FOR ELECTION
RESULTS AND GHANA, IN VENEZUELA
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF IT, THEY
TAILOR THEIR BALLOTS WITHIN
HOURS, SUDDENLY WE CAN'T MANAGE
TO DO THAT?
CLARK COUNTY NEVADA, THE HOME O
LAS VEGAS AS THEY ARE STILL TEN
OF THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS LEFT TO
COUNSEL WE WANT KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE ELECTION UNTIL
MONDAY, WE HOPE.
OFFICIALS IN CLARK COUNTY ARE
CURRENTLY OVERWHELMED BEAR
THEY'RE TOO BUSY TO FINISH THE
ONE JOB THEY ARE PAID TO DO, IT
STRANGELY THEY HAVE TIME TO
ATTACK DELMO TRUMP ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, WHICH THEY'VE BEEN DOING
ALL DAY.
IT'S NOT JUST NEVADA AND ARIZONA
.
KEY HOUSE RACES ALONG THE WEST
COAST OF THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA
OREGON, IN WASHINGTON STATE ARE
STILL UNSETTLED TONIGHT.
THERE SAYING THEY HAVEN'T
COUNTED THE VOTES.
REALLY?
WHAT IS THIS?
IS THIS FRAUD?
WE'RE NOT SURE.
ON SOME LEVEL IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT IT IS, WHAT WE KNOW IS THA
THE MECHANICS OF OUR ELECTIONS
ARE NOT WORKING, ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY IN STATES RUN BY
DEMOCRATS.
ARE THEY CHEATING?
ARE THEY DISORGANIZED?
NOT RELEVANT.
THIS SYSTEM IS OBVIOUSLY OUT OF
CONTROL.
IT IS FLAKY AND SYSTEMS LIKE
THAT CANNOT BE, BY DEFINITION
RELIABLE, WOULD YOU LET MARICOP
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIAL PLAYER
AIRCRAFT?
PROBABLY NOT VERY DEMOCRACY IS
FAITH-BASED SYSTEM.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IN IT IN
ORDER FOR IT TO WORK.
WHO CAN BELIEVE IN THIS?
OUR NEWS MEDIA, HAS SPENT THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS QUOTE
DEFENDING DEMOCRACY.
SO YOU WOULD THINK THAT
DEMOCRACY DEFENDERS WOULD CARE
ABOUT THE COLLAPSE OF.
IT WILL BE CENSORED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AS WE FOUND OUT TODAY.
TWITTER A WARNING LABEL ON
VIDEOS FROM THE SHOW BECAUSE WE
REPORTED VERIFIABLE FACTS FROM
ELECTION OFFICIALS ABOUT
ELECTIONS GROUPS.
IT IS TAKING WEEKS TO COUNT THE
BALLOTS IN YOUR DEMOCRACY, BUT
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO NOTICE IT
.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
WE ARE NOT SURE.
AT THIS STAGE THERE IS NO WAY T
KNOW BECAUSE WE'RE NOT MEAN OUT
THE ALLEGATIONS WITHOUT WOULD
ASK THE MOST OBVIOUS QUESTION O
ALL TO SEE IF WE COULD FIND THE
ANSWER.
THE QUESTION IS WHO IS
BENEFITING FROM THIS AND HOW DO
YOU KNOW.
IN CASES WHERE THERE WAS CHAOS
AND DELAYS OVER THE LAST SEVERA
ELECTION CYCLES, WHAT PERCENTAG
OF THE ULTIMATE TURNED OUT TO B
DEMOCRATS.
IN A FAIR SYSTEM, HE WOULD THIN
ABORTION WOULD LAND AROUND 50
PERCENT, A COIN TOSS, BUT WE
CHECKED AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
AND 13 RECENT RACES, ELECTION
DELAYS WERE PUBLICIZED FROM
INTENT OF THEM POINTING TO THE
DEMOCRAT PRETEND OUT OF 14, 77
PERCENT, THAT'S NOT A COIN
TOSS, THAT'S A HIGH AVERAGE.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE 2018
ELECTION AND ORANGE COUNTY,
CALIFORNIA,.
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES IN
ORDER TO COUNTY HAD HUGE LEADS
ON ELECTION DAY.
IN THE WEEKS FOLLOWING THE
ELECTION, THOSE LEADS
DISAPPEARED, THEY EVAPORATED.
IN THE END, DEMOCRATS CLICK
CLIPPED EACH OF THOSE SEATS.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
REPORT THAT TO HUNDRED THOUSAND
VOTES BY MAIL DROP OFF BALLOTS
CAME IN.
MANY OF THOSE BALLOTS WERE
BROUGHT INTO POLLING STATION BY
PAID PALLET HARVESTERS.
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER PUT
IT THIS WAY QUOTE PEOPLE WERE
CARRYING AND STACKS OF 10200 OF
THEM.
MULTIPLE PEOPLE CALLING TO ASK
IF THESE PEOPLE WERE ALLOWED TO
DO THIS RATE OF COURSE THEY WER
ALLOWED.
THAT'S THE POINT.
THIS SUDDEN REVERSALS DIDN'T
JUST HAPPEN IN ORANGE COUNTY,
CALIFORNIA.
IN THE STATES CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT THE PRESS DECLARED THE
WINNER, BECAUSE IT WAS AT LEADS
ON ELECTION NIGHT.
THE AP DOES NOT CALL RACES FOR
REPUBLICANS UNLESS THEY ARE
PRETTY SURE.
IN THIS CASE THEY HAD TO RETRAC
FOR CALL NEARLY THREE WEEKS
LATER AFTER HIS THEY DOCUMENTED
THE LENGTHY, SON ELECTION NIGHT.
AFTER A LONG EVENING OF TORTUOU
DELAY FOLLOWING A HISTORIC
MIDTERM ELECTION THE RESULTS
WERE IN NWA PROMISED BRIGHT
NEVADA DEMOCRATS BECAME A
DEFINITIVE REALITY.
IT WAS THE SAME STORY THAT YEAR
AND PLACES LIKE DETROIT AND
ARIZONA, IT TOOK DAYS FOR ALL
THE VOTES TO BE COUNTED IN THE
STATE OF ARIZONA.
YOU WILL NOT BE SHOCKED TO LEAR
THAT MARTHA MAKE SALLY NEARLY
LOST HER RACE FOR THE SENATE.
HERE YOU HAVE LENGTHY DELAYS IN
VOTE COUNTING FOLLOWED BY GOOD
NEWS FOR DEMOCRATS.
IT HAS HAPPENED OVER THE COUNTRY
.
IN 2020 IT TOOK OFFICIAL SIX
WEEKS TO DECLARE A WINNER IN TH
CONGRESSIONAL PRIMARY FOR TWO
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF NEW
YORK.
IN THE END, BECAUSE THESE WERE
PRIMARIES, THERE WAS AN INTERIM
PARTY CONTEST, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ESTABLISHMENT, THE MOST
PART A POWERFUL PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ONE BRIGHT
LONGTIME CONGRESSWOMAN FENDED
OFF AN INSURGENT PROGRESSIVE
SUCCESSFULLY AFTER LONG DELAYS
AND RICHIE TORRES DEFEATED HIS
CHALLENGER WHO IS A CONSERVATIV
DEMOCRAT.
WEIRD HOW THAT WORKS FOR IT
SEVERAL YEARS EARLIER, THE SAME
THING HAPPENED TO REPUBLICANS I
TERMS OF THE SCOPE.
IN ELECTION NIGHT IN 2014 IN TH
SUBURBS, IT LOOKED LIKE A
REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER ABOUT TO
UNSEAT DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN O
THE REPUBLICAN UP MORE THAN
3,000 VOTES, BUT TWO WEEKS LATER
, MORE VOTES CAME IN AND
GUESS WHAT, THE DEMOCRAT WAS
DECLARED THE WINNER BY 700 VOTES
.
HE HAS BEEN IN CONGRESS EVER
SINCE.
IN ALL THE RECENT CASES WE
LOOKED AT, ONLY THE STATE OF
FLORIDA HAD A LONG VOTING COUNT
DELAYED THAT LED TO A REPUBLICA
IT WASN'T JUST ONE COUNTY BIRD
THAT WAS IN THE 2018 FLORIDA
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION WHEN
INCUMBENT DEMOCRATS BROKE THE
LAW AND FAILED TO REPORT VOTE
TOTALS FOR FOUR DAYS.
ON TUESDAY, THINGS TO EFFORTS T
IMPROVE VOTE COUNTING, FLORIDA
TABULATE THE RESULTS MORE
QUICKLY.
SO FLORIDA IS FAR BIGGER THAN
ARIZONA OR NEVADA, BUT BY
CONTRAST HAD ITS ELECTION
RESULTS AS YOU KNOW IN A SINGLE
DAY.
BY THE WAY, FLORIDA ENFORCES
VOTER AID D STRICTLY.
SO NO MATTER WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT HIM AND HIS POLICIES, IF
YOU AREN'T ON A PERSON YOU MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IS A WIN FOR
DEMOCRACY.
THE SYSTEM WORKED, THE VOTES
WERE COUNTED.
THEY WERE REPORTED PROMPTLY.
DEMOCRACY ONE IN FLORIDA EVEN I
THE OUTCOME IS NOT YOUR
PREFERENCE.
NO ONE IN THE MEDIA SEEMED
IMPRESSED BY THE SPIRIT HERE IS
CNN RHONDA SANTOS ACTUALLY GAME
THE SYSTEM.
CAN GET YESTERDAY HE WON BY 20
PERCENTAGE POINTS FRAID WHY?
BECAUSE HE GAINED THE SYSTEM.
HE TURNED INTO AN UNLEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
THEY CHANGED ELECTION LAWS
MAKING IT HARDER TO VOTE BY MAIL
.
THEY PARADED A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
COME UP BLACK PEOPLE THAT THEY
ARRESTED FOR VOTING FRAUD AND
PARADED THEM IN FRONT OF
NATIONAL MEDIA.
HE CREATED AN ELECTION POLICE
PARITY ALSO WAS VERY GOOD AT
RESPONDING TO HURRICANES IN
OTHER TRAGEDIES.
HE GETS SO BY FIGHTING ELECTION
FRAUD, HE GAMED THE SYSTEM.
HE CERTAINLY DID, HE GAMED THEI
SYSTEM.
WE OUGHT TO DEMAND THAT EVERY
SYSTEM GAMES THEIR SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO GAMED THAT EVERY
ELECTION IN AMERICA LOOKS LIKE
FLORIDA'S ELECTION NOT IN ITS
OUTCOME, BUT IN THE WAY IT IS
CONDUCTED.
ONLY REGISTERED VOTERS CAN VOTE.
THEY MUST VOTE IN THEIR OWN
NAMES, THEY CAN ONLY VOTE ONCE
AND YOU GET TO KNOW THAT RESULTS
, YOU THE CITIZEN